muchos de nosotros hemos tenido la
oportunidad de ver volar a gansos o
gaviotas y tal vez nos hemos preguntado
por qué vuelan
teniendo esta formación en vez
esta forma no es casual es una manera de
volar más lejos y gastar menos de
energía es un trabajo colaborativo en
donde el líder es el que rompe el viento
es el que guía y también es el que le
tea más fuerte y cuando él se cansa da
paso al segundo de la formación ya sea
del lado derecho o del lado izquierdo y
pasa al final toman turnos
y la naturaleza como vemos y desde la
perspectiva evolutiva la colaboración
mutua es un factor sumamente importante
para sobrevivir
especialmente aquellos organismos
sociales como las abejas las hormigas
los elefantes los delfines y los seres
humanos
y si de las de la perspectiva evolutiva
estamos llamados a colaborar porque no
lo hacemos
tal vez no nos damos cuenta que estamos
colaborando todo el tiempo
y que nuestro alrededor existen muchas
redes de colaboración que no las estamos
tomando en cuenta
pensemos en nuestra familia en mi caso
mi familia extendida
que jugó un papel sumamente importante
durante mis estudios de doctorado ya se
podrán imaginar ser un doctorado con dos
pequeños nada sencillo pero el hecho de
saber que les tenía a mi familia al otro
lado de una llamada de una videollamada
o que mi madre mis hermanas me podían
acompañar por dos o tres semanas de
organizarme mientras mi esposo estaba
haciendo el trabajo de campo era un gran
alivio
y este objetivo mi objetivo personal de
lograr un doctorado se convirtió no
solamente en mío sino de toda mi red
familiar y no solamente logramos un
doctorado logramos dos mi esposo y yo
nos graduamos del doctorado con un mes
de diferencia que en el mundo académico
es un evento sumamente raro fue un gran
desafío de pareja
de familia de mi núcleo familiar de mis
hijos y de mi esposo pero
definitivamente no lo hubiéramos logrado
si no hubiéramos tenido esa red de
soporte familiar
pero hay veces en que la red no es no
existe y te toca crearlas
cuando estaba empezando mi doctorado
salía corriendo de las clases y después
recogía mi pequeño en la guardería y a
mi pequeña en la escuela arreglábamos
las cosas en la casa y nuestra siguiente
parada eran los juegos infantiles
y mientras los pequeños jugaban las
mamás leíamos escribíamos hacíamos
trabajos académicos
y el conversar nos dimos cuenta que
teníamos las mismas preocupaciones las
mismas perspectivas y decidimos formar
el grupo pies de mouse madres y
estudiantes la mayoría de nosotras
internacionales y madres solteras para
ayudarnos a generar no solamente ese
soporte emocional sino también eso esa
red de soporte y de cuidado de nuestros
pequeños
así que cuando dos o tres teníamos
tiempo nos íbamos a encargar de los
hijos de todas les llevábamos al parque
y jugábamos con ellos mientras tanto el
resto estaban en la biblioteca en los
laboratorios en sus casas escribiendo
sus tesis
este grupo nos ayudó
aquí no votemos la toalla y mitad del
camino
y todas las que pertenecemos a pies de
manos este momento estamos graduadas con
nuestras maestrías y nuestros doctorados
con toda esa energía y con toda esta
experiencia en colaboración regresé a mi
país pero me encontré con una realidad
completamente diferente una realidad de
puertas cerradas en donde colaborar e
investigar
un verdadero desafío es un acto de
rebeldía el sistema académico
y en esa situación las redes llegaron a
mi vida paradójicamente a través del
facebook
mujeres que se sentían igual que yo
que habían regresado de sus doctorados y
de sus maestrías
estaban buscando un grupo un espacio
para dialogar
y por eso formamos la red ecuatoriana de
mujeres científicas más de 100 mujeres
en todo el ecuador que luchamos por
mayor equidad en las ciencias
la red se ha convertido y nos ha ayudado
a encontrar nuestra voz
la red ha sido para muchas de nosotras
esa energía y ese oxígeno para quedarnos
en el país y para seguir luchando en
contracorriente
no es fácil todo el tiempo pero si
ponemos en una balanza las cosas buenas
y nuestras derrotas siempre lo bueno va
a ser
la red a lo largo de este tiempo nos ha
motivado la red nos ha protegido la red
nos empodera y sin darnos cuenta hemos
empezado a avanzar juntas más lejos y
vivir el efecto flan a no
el efecto flanagan surge en los deportes
específicamente en el maratón un deporte
individual de resistencia
se le infla nada fue la primera mujer
que ganó la maratón después de 40 años
en la ciudad de nueva york
y eso que le llevó también a conseguir
un montón de premios y medallas
muchas mujeres querían entrenar con ella
pero querían entrenar para vencerla
ellas enternador se sentaron y
analizaron una nueva estrategia porque
la estrategia no era vencerla ya le
inflan algo es vencernos a nosotros es
vencer al reloj buscar un objetivo
colectivo una meta común
en donde no importe quién gana con tal
de que una de las del grupo gane y con
el paso del tiempo empezaron a ver que
flanagan no solamente brillaba con sus
logros sino con los logros del equipo
a eso se le conoce como el efecto
flanagan
rodearnos de gente que nos ayude a
avanzar más lejos y juntos
pero como se genera una red
buscando esas personas que tienen el
mismo objetivo y que lo creen
igual que tú
así como los gansos y como las gaviotas
tomando la posta comunicándose
aprendiendo de diferentes perspectivas
entendiendo que todos tenemos fortalezas
y debilidades
aprendiendo además que hay veces que
puedes trabajar mejor con unas personas
y con otras no de la red pero que igual
sigues aportando al objetivo como y sin
darte cuenta estarán avanzando juntas
esto de las redes no es nada nuevo está
ahí en nuestras vidas
pensemos en la familia en el colegio en
la escuela
cuando nosotros nos llevamos de pequeños
o ahora un primo nos invita a una
reunión y de pronto conocemos a sus
amigos estamos ampliando nuestra red de
contactos
o en la escuela y el colegio cuando un
profesor te invitó a ese club de
natación de ciencias y de pronto
conociste a muchísimos otros chicos y
chicas que estaban en otros grados en
otros cursos del colegio o de la escuela
o en el caso de la universidad cuando
una profesora o profesor te abre las
puertas para que participes en ese grupo
de investigación
al revés están ahí todo el tiempo están
allí pero tal vez es el problema que no
le estamos dando la importancia y no nos
han enseñado a generar redes de
fortalecerlas
no sé si
un profesor que a lo largo de su vida
les ha invitado a ir a un evento
académico pero no solamente asistir al
evento sino ir a las fiestas ir a los
cócteles ir a las reuniones adicionales
para que conozcan más gente
usualmente qué es lo que hacemos vamos a
los simposios a los congresos nos
sentamos muchas veces ni siquiera
preguntamos y cuando se acaba el evento
lo único que esperamos es que nos den
nuestro certificado de participación
cuando el punto más importante del
evento es la posibilidad de conocer
gente de crear redes esas redes que son
sumamente importantes a nivel
profesional o pensemos en el lado social
cuando te vas a una fiesta o una reunión
social y solo conversas con la gente que
conoces porque no nos damos la opción de
conocer gente nueva porque no nos
inscribimos en un curso de pintura donde
no conocemos a nadie un curso de cocina
abrir esa red de contactos que es tan
importante
actualmente la individualidad es
premiada en nuestra sociedad
especialmente en la academia que es de
donde yo vengo
el mejor investigador la mujer del año
el gerente del año la mejor actriz
pero a veces nos olvidamos que detrás de
ese hombre o mujer del año de ese mejor
investigador de ese mejor vendedor
hay productos hay resultados hay un
trabajo hay una red
una red que nos ayuda a seguir avanzando
una red que nos ayuda a salir adelante
las investigaciones nos demuestran en el
área académica
que cuando hay más colaboración el
impacto de los resultados es mucho mayor
incluso si hablamos de citas un trabajo
que tiene mayor colaboración puede
llegar hasta un 30% más de citas
entonces que estamos esperando para
abrirnos a colaborar
porque en la siguiente reunión o evento
nos sentamos al lado de alguien que no
conocemos porque no revisamos a nuestro
alrededor y vemos esas redes de
colaboración que están ahí
fortalezcamos activemos de esas redes y
descubramos donde necesitamos poner
énfasis y empezar a crear esas redes que
son tan importantes y cuando estén
liderando ese grupo esa red
recuerden el comportamiento de los
gansos y las gaviotas que cuando el
líder se cansa que cuando el líder se
debilita
se dé el paso
se dé el paso al siguiente por el bien
del grupo para llegar más lejos juntos
porque definitivamente el trabajo en
colaboración nos lleva a superar
nuestras limitaciones y nuestras
expectativas
[Aplausos]